so this is joint work with dings Nikki
Bella fanned avatar dose in this work we
are interested in a very basic economic
task which is inferring the private
parameters of strategic agents by
observing their strategic interactions
more specifically we're going to be
thinking of the following instantiation
of this basic economic task with the
task which is inferring the values of
players for an item by observing this
their sequence of beads in some auction
for the Titan so here's the situation
I'm imagining you have an option that is
repeated over time many times and you
have a set of bidders that are
participating in this auction repeatedly
and they have some private valuation for
this for the item that is being
auctioned now based on their valuation
and based on some beliefs that they
might have or some arguing like about
the competition in the auction they're
going to submit some big and here we are
the economic tensions we're going to
observe this sequence of beads that are
submitted in this auction and based on
the sequence of bits that we observe we
want to infer these private values that
the players have for this item okay now
in order to accomplish such a task one
basic assumption that one needs to make
is to assume how will players be decide
what action to take what bid to
submitting this auction based on their
beliefs and based on I don't know like
how the argue about competition so the
standard approaching econometrics and in
economics is to assume that the behavior
the players are going to take an
instruction is going to be an ass
equilibrium or baseness equilibrium if
these valuations are drawn from some
distribution and are not fixed but from
data we observed that this Nash
equilibrium assumption is not so
realistic and in fact like we observed
that people went so the here I'm
portraying for example a sponsor search
auction from bing and these are the bits
of a single advertiser for who is
participating repeatedly and these are
his bid for different keywords that he's
participating in and this is a period of
a week and we see that he changes his
bid very frequently and this cannot be
the case that he's changing his values
Ben is changing all the time during this
period of a week so if it was an ass
equilibria let's say pure Nash
equilibria meet with
that you his bid would be stable but
this is not what we observe so other
ties in this auction must be doing
something else other than a Nash
equilibrium and in fact this is
reinforced by by the fact that most of
these advertisers in the sponsorships
auctions are using very sophisticated
building tools decide what they bead and
this building tools even they claim that
they do some dynamic optimization in
their in their advertisement so they're
not doing some equipment computation
sure maybe the others are the updated
exactly stationary behavior exactly so
that's what that's going to be my
assumption that they're learning agents
that they're nothing ms equilibrium but
that they're learning agents and we're
going to try to do a condo matrix okay
so this is the main point of the paper
and thanks for introducing it okay so
okay so I'm gonna assume another model
of learning that's not like a sequential
Nash equilibrium learning okay so which
is based on actually some of your
workouts so so stationary Nash
equilibria it disproves that one exactly
ok yeah so so this is what we're going
to assume in this but in this work and
try to the chromatics we're going to
assume that the ends are going to use
some learning algorithms to play
repeatedly in disrepute adduction and so
any learning algorithm would look as
follows you do the update he Sturridge
based on past observation so we assume
that you know bid's people submit
sumbitted it's time step based on the
past history of of bits that they have
observed of play of all the players and
we're going to make an assumption that
implies that maybe in the beginning
players don't submit an optimal bit but
over time they will learn to bid
something that is approximately optimal
and the main assumption that we're going
to make the concrete ahsan you're gonna
make is that the the bidders are going
to use some learning algorithm that
seems vanishing regret and what do I
mean by one is in regret I mean that the
average utility that they acquired from
the bit that they submitted over time is
at least as good as the average utility
that they would have gotten by playing a
fixed bit over time assuming that all
the rest of the play
remain fixed at what they did minus a
mirror term that vanishes 20 as they
play more and more games so this is the
definition of a vanishing cricket and
why do we make this assumption first of
all there are many simple outgoings that
achieved is no regret assumption and
even stronger the conditions and no
regret such as multiplicative weight
updates or regret matching by harden
Maskull L and what is home for all
strategy alternate strategy profiles or
we're all alternative beads so you fix
what you observed it has to hold that
for any other beat that this player
could have submitted for any other
action is the newest regret strategy
equality holds no matter what so the the
assumption the learning algorithm would
be for whatever sequence but for our
method to work it has to only apply to
the sequence that we observe but yeah
there are some key assumptions that for
any adversarial sequence that you might
observe that the other players are doing
of opponent strategies you satisfy this
condition and there are algorithms that
achieve this stronger property the other
good thing about this not good
assumption is that most of these
algorithms can work even if the players
get some very limited feedback about the
option that they're participating in so
they don't need to know anything about
the competition or the parameters of the
option they only need to observe after
every iteration what is the utility from
the bit that they submitted and this is
important for example in applications
like sponsor search where players
definitely don't know exactly the option
that's being run and also don't know
what are the competitors that are going
to participate in each individual
impression okay also this not get
assumption is somewhat mean it's this
like it's a somewhat minimal requirement
from the behavior of the learning
algorithm it just says that you don't
regret any fixed bit over time most
probably any learning algorithm to
satisfy this condition and it would even
satisfy stronger conditions that you
might not even regret some slowly
changing bit over time or something that
the last one is that even if you follow
the start the sander econometrica proach
and you assume that it
iteration the behavior that you observed
was an ass equilibrium of the
corresponding complete information game
then such a behavior would also be
another great sequence and so even if
you were making data you know our
requirement is inclusive of that
assumption so it's even more it's even
even more about the assumption to make
yeah that's true even if it's a what
you're observing with a base Nash
equilibrium through realized did some
phase Nash's yes I'm assuming a fixed
basic when if sequence of bits this for
in this works I don't know like what
would happen if beats are varying over
time presumably you would in the longer
run you would also get some equivalence
with business equilibria but I'm not
sure so here's the main goal we want to
infer private parameters of these
participants in this auction assuming
that the observed behavior has a small
regret
this is a high-level approach if we
assume some epsilon regret then we get a
set of inequalities that the observed
behavior must satisfy so it must be for
any fixed bid of the players their
average utility must be at least the the
average utility they would have gotten
from this fixed bid mine summer term
Absalom so this would give that give a
set of inequalities that the observed
the private parameter must satisfy and
if you take epsilon if you if you value
absalon this would give you the whole
set of values that are rationalized ball
under epsilon regret so for a fixed
epsilon this set of inequalities would
give you the values of the Russian Eliza
before epsilon regret and if you also
very epsilon you would get a whole
rationale is able set which is the set
of values that are rationalized will
under some absolutely regret for some
obscure your drinks is just once a
capital T yes just once so for now
moving just once at capital T and I'm
going to mention some future where we
trying to now to do more dynamic
approach then when we apply this method
to data we're going to and give some
angry because we're going to give some
interesting summary statistics we're
going to have to pick some point in this
rationalize herbal said so to give some
specific prediction of the value and the
possible or grade of the player and I'm
going to discuss that when i get to the
data analysis part of the doc so here is
the specific model that we're going to
use which is a sponsor shirts auction
setting so we're going to assume that
this player is but we have a set of
advertisers that are participating in
this sponsor search auction and it has
some value per click VI with the skis
private parameter bidders submit some
bit to the to the option and they
arrived according to some scoring rule
which incorporates their bid and some
other quality factors which are very
noisy and then based on the position
they have some probability of being
clicked and with season typically
increasing the position and then they
also pay some function of the next
highest bid which can also be some very
complicated function of that bit the
main assumption that we're going to make
is that the utility of the play
disposal in ear which means that for any
bid that he submits his utility is his
value times the probability that he that
he's being clicked minus the expected
payment he has to make now for such
quasi-linear utilities now everything
becomes much easier the Russian Eliza
bull said you can earn a cup you can
prove that it has much more structure
than general utility settings so all
that matters in the characterizing the
rationalize able set is what is the
increase in the probability of clicker
that would get if i switch to a fixed
bid x so this is like here assuming
everyone else is fixed this is the
average probability that I of being
click that I would get if i switch to
this X and this is what I currently got
and the average of our all periods and
similarly what is the increase in the
expected cost that I need to make if I
switch to this fixed bit x and now the
sequence of beads this sequence of bits
is going to have a regret most Epsilon
if the following inequality holds the
increase in my total value which is
linked the my value per click x the
Englishman in my probability of being
clicked mine is my increase in mycosis
be at most epsilon so if it was a purely
if the epson was zero than you you know
if people were truly best responding you
would get that you cannot increase your
your value more than you could increase
your expected cost by switching to a
fixed speed now an interesting point to
make is that even though the rules of
which individual generalized second
price auction that is being run at its
impression is very deterministic and
discontinuous because we're taking an
average here and because there's a lot
of noisiness in the ranking score the
actual the upper it's increasing
probability of clicking in the average
cost as a function of a fixed bid I
actually going to turn out to be in most
of the data sets that we looked at
continuous functions so you're going to
see some sort of sort of concave
increasing probability of click as a
function of your fixed bid and some sort
of convex increasing payment so we're
going to make such continue it
assumptions in the paper when analyzing
the infinites properties of this
rationalize able set
okay so let me now go into some
inference properties of the last but
this rationalize double set and then
I'll switch to the data and then some
simulation data so these are the Russian
illegible set is characterized by the
set of inequalities which for any fixed
X these are just linear functions of V
and epsilon so for any fixed X you're
going to get a line and it says that the
the value of the player has to be sorry
for any fixed value for this value to be
rationalized able they regret must be at
least some some amount right so the pair
of values and regrets have to lie above
this line and then for another line
you're going to get another feasible
region and so the rationalize double set
is going to be the intersection of all
these lines which is going to be a
convex function a convex set sorry so
the first easy characterization is that
is rationalized able set is a convex set
and from that you can get a lot of
leverage it here's for example how these
rationalize double sets look from real
data from sponsor search and you see
that they have this nice continuous form
that I assumed here and what is the
level that we can get from this the fact
that the set is convex well we can get
that it's characterized by what is
called the support function of this
convex set which is basically if you
haven't seen that is basically for any
direction you you're going to take this
line that corresponds to this direction
you and you're going to push it until it
touches the boundary of this convex set
and then the value of the support
function for this direction you is
simply the distance from the origin of
this line okay so every convex set is
uniquely characterized by its support
function so in fearing this rationalize
able set from data is equivalent to
inferring this support function and then
we saw that this support function of
this specific rationalize able set is
uniquely determined by the care that the
between the increasing probability of
click versus the increasing cost so if
you plot this to them at this single
dimensional curve that on the x-axis has
the increasing in my cost for a fixed
bit and here has the increase in the in
my probability of being clicked and you
plot this curve here this curve is going
to uniquely characterize the support
function of this rationalize herbal set
and so in flaring this single
dimensional curve is equivalent to
inferring the support function which is
equivalent inferring the Russian
eligible set so everything boils down to
just a inference of the single
dimensional function which can be done
with very very very few samples of the
auctions okay and what I mean buying by
very few samples of the auctions I mean
that during its period that the player
is changing his bead the player might be
participating in many many auctions and
because might be too costly to simulate
what would have happened in each of
these auctions because we need to go and
simulate what would have happened with
any other alternative bid we might want
to use like a sample of these auctions
and assuming that during two big changes
the behavior of the auctions are sort of
like so hostage and so we might only
usually when I use a some sample of
destruction which is going to introduce
some sampling error and because we
reduced our inference problem by
two-dimensional inference problem to a
single dimensional inference problem
we're going to need the we're going to
have very fast estimation properties as
a function of this number of samples
that we got so this is just to make the
inference of desertion Eliza beset
computationally much faster okay
so I'm going to switch to the data
analysis part any questions of the state
so we analyzed 9 frequent be changing
advertisers in Microsoft sponsored Inc
in this in the Bing sponsored search
auction system and it's a bird
advertiser has several listings we're
listing is basically a keyboard and the
bid pair so I'm bidding this from this
amount for this key for being for
appearing in the left hand side of the
for the specific keyword that is being
searched and we applied this inference
method for its listing of its advertiser
and then to get some summary statistics
we use the following point prediction
method so we use the value that
corresponds to the smallest
multiplicative regret now and by
multiplicative I mean instead of having
an additive error epsilon put here a
multiplicative error lambda and then
find the smallest lambda for which this
is satisfied and output the value that
corresponds to the smallest lambda and
why do you use the smallest
multiplicative regret because then we
want to compare these predictions across
different these predictions of regret
and value across different listings of
the advertiser and the multiplicative
version takes away some pathologies such
as that in one keyword the player might
have a huge value and so a small regret
might be a small additive regret for
such a huge value might be reasonable
and then we're comparing it to a small
additive regret for another listing
where he had has a very small value and
so this is not these are not comparable
but when we take go to the
multiplicative it takes away this
heterogeneity in values that the players
might have four different keywords okay
so how does this look like in the
rationalize herbal said basically we're
taking this rationalize above set we're
taking a point here which corresponds to
the current possible the current
probability of being clicked of the
player and the current cost that he's
paying and basically the smallest the
lambda corresponds to plotting a line
here and taking the largest coefficient
until the this line touches the
rationalize herbal said and this is the
specific point that we're going to
predict over here okay
so here are some statistics that we got
so but first of all we compare the
prediction that we that we got from this
inference method to the average speed of
the advertiser and we get that on
average people be the almost 60
approximately sixty percent of their of
their predicted value so the average
speed of the advertiser is like sixty
percent of the value that we predict
which is a pretty reasonable conclusion
so that was sort of like reinforcing
that we're doing something right here we
also get that the smallest regret has
this the histogram of the smallest
ergott has this sort of consistently
this sort of distribution there are a
lot of listings that have almost zero
regrets so they might be best responding
there might be at a Nash equilibrium etc
and there are several other listings
that have large multiplicative regret
ranging from zero to fifty percent so
you might say that these are there's a
large fraction that might have arrived
at an equilibrium or at an almost the
best response and there's another set of
listings that are maybe in their
learning phase another small observation
that we made is that there's a
correlation between how much regret you
have in mohammed's you said your bead
and we get here that when people are in
the learning phase or when they have
higher grade they say their bit more so
they bid less than than what they they
tend to beat when they have smaller grid
so when they're more in the equilibrium
phase
next we also did some simulated data so
we to see that at least I reckon America
approach is valid and when our
assumptions are valid we sort of
simulated running GSP over time and play
and we simulated some bidders that are
running multiplicative weight updates
over time and then we applied our
econometrics approach to the observed
history of beads and we saw whether we
recover the values that we put to the
bidders when they were running the
multiplicative great updates so we run
GSP for several iterations we used
uncertain quality scores to simulate
what is happening in practice and then
it each of these advertisers was
applying multiplicative weight updates
for some value that we said which was
drawn from some distribution we also had
some advertisers playing bidding
truthfully some fixed bid to simulate
what is actually happening also in
practice and then we applied inference
method to the learning players and these
are sort of the Russian Eliza both sets
that we got and the true points of the
advertisers so here these are like this
is a simulation with five advertisers
and this is the rationale is able set
after several iterations and here you
can see that this is the true point so
this is the true value of the advertiser
and this is his true regret and what is
nice here is that we do get that the
true point is actually very close to the
to the tip of this rationalize above set
as time goes by so predicting some value
around the steep even real data might be
a good point prediction method sugar I'm
sorry yes yes regret you go to zero yes
so this is a so this is like the
rationalize opposite over time so this
point is going down to zero the yes Tom
goes down exactly yes so these are
rationalized able sets over time and the
true point goes down and it's sort of
like pushing the tip of the of the
rationalize able set down and eventually
when it goes to zero you can actually
show that with some uncertain quality
scores that the tip will be the you know
the tip of this are generalizable said
would be the true point can actually
formerly so it for some and there's some
assumptions on the on the noise in the
in the GSP but eventually the true point
will be the tip okay and so for example
here is also the distribution we run it
several times where values were drawn
from some Gaussian distribution and this
is the distribution of errors that we
get so if this is the distribution of
errors with if we predicted the actual
tip which is the smallest additive
regret and this is the distribution of
errors if we predict the smallest
multiplicative very good which is what
you used in the data and we see that the
smallest man look at you put some
positive bias on the on the prediction
so there are some positive bias here
which is not here and so the one
observation which is happening basically
because for very small values of the
distribution there are a lot of
equivalent best response bits and we
cannot differentiate these values and
what are econometrics method tends to do
for this values is over suit and predict
something slightly higher so we're so
this is a true value distribution from
these simulations this is what we
predicted based on the smallest additive
regret and this is what we would predict
based on the smallest multiplicative
regret and we almost get the right shape
subject to these pathologies in the
smallest value regime so let me conclude
so the data so that players have a small
but nonzero or greater than our frequent
bit changers so if we want to handle
such data set we need to use some
learning model in our econometrics
methods and so we propose an economic
method based of the of based on this
naughty great learning a theory and
there are several next steps that one
can take from this so currently we're
looking at some more dynamic analysis of
this rationalize able set and whether
they're great it's actually going to 0
another very hard task is to actually do
some inference on the actual learning
algorithm that the users are doing or
some sort of like abstract model of the
learning algorithm and try to fit some
learning some update rule for the
advertisers another approach that we're
taking is to directly infer the out some
properties of the outcomes rather than
the values directly so you might want to
infer how efficient the outcome is
without actually inferring the true
values and get some
on the efficiency from the data and
we're exploring with dar el and denis
nikiforov whether we can do such things
with by dropping some of our assumptions
for this paper such as that the fact
that the values were constant over time
so we are looking at whether we can
handle both learning players and
valuations changing over time and
predict some price of energy from data
when which is going to breed sort of the
gap between the worst case price of Eric
guarantees from theory and econometrics
guarantees from data one could also look
at other bidder objectives other than
this class winner utility model so this
is so there are several other objectives
that advertisers are interested in such
a return on investment and stuff like
that so you might also want to apply you
could apply the nore great learning
approach to other bidder objectives and
I think the Holy Grail in all this line
of work is sort of track being able to
predict long-term effect when we change
the auction from one to another and
without making the assumption that
people are going to be at equilibria so
sort of like even if people are learning
over time we want to see what is the
long-term revenue effect or efficiency
effective we change from this auction to
another auction and I hope that online
learning theory could be useful tool at
taking a stab at this like very
difficult task thank
you say that people see their bit more
uncertain and yesterday better me like
the risk aversion dominates the intent
to play explorin that's what my
interpretation of it yes that we they're
more uncertain as well have what's
happening so I'm more conservative you
like how do you know that when you see
people with high regrets they're just
people who are not satisfying the
assumptions of your model and so the
inference is wrong maybe but yeah so
people with higher it might not be doing
no regret so that the dynamic analysis
would actually is exactly going to
tackle this [ __ ] at least if I see
that they regret is vanishing sort of
then they are still in the you know
inside the the model so i think that's
that's there that's going to be the
answer to this question i guess yeah
okay thank you thank you